we had a transgen transvestite Nanny my
bike got stolen one day and he got it
back for me in a in a wig like you know
it's the mean streets in New Orleans
this is pre-camera phone pre-wifi when
it was like racial tension tough we were
the white family and these kids you know
Street Urban youths uh also known as
black they uh they were taking my bike
apart on the on the stoop and I said
that's my bike you know I was in the car
hiding and he goes all right hang here
and he just yanked it out of their hand
and they're like going nuts like look at
this [__] eye you know because it was
the 90s and they're holding tools and
[__] and he still just was Fearless
enough to just take the bike back and
like look him in the eye and walk to the
van and put the bike in and we drove
home [__] yeah this is my male robot
yeah in a wig I love and heels and heels
that's [__] great he could move in
those heels